monsieur le ministre mes chers collègues
l'ordre du jour appelle l'examen des
conclusions de la commission mixte
paritaire chargée d'élaborer un texte
sur les dispositions restant en
discussion du projet de loi relatif aux
renseignements
dans la discussion générale la parole
est d'abord à monsieur philippe bas
rapporteur pour le sénat de la
commission mixte paritaire
monsieur le président merci monsieur le
président monsieur le président de la
commission des affaires étrangères et de
la défense madame la présidente de la
commission des lois il est bien sûr
monsieur le ministre et charles
collègues le sénat aborder la discussion
de ce texte avec une ambition en faire
une loi républicaine inscrivant pour la
première fois la politique française du
renseignement dans le cadre de notre
état de droit
tout au long de nos débats
nous avons cherché à rejoindre la grande
tradition du sénat république garant de
la protection des libertés publiques
refusant toute législation d'exception
choisissant au contraire d'inscrire la
mise en oeuvre des techniques modernes
de renseignement dans le droit commun du
contrôle qui s'applique à toute autorité
publique dans l'exercice de ses
prérogatives au service de l'intérêt
général sont en effet en jeu d'un côté
la protection de la vie humaine et la
poursuite d'intérêts fondamentaux de la
nation et de l'autre le respect de la
vie privée
le secret des correspondances la liberté
depuis 1789 nous admettons que tout
droit toute liberté même les plus
inviolable les plus sacrées connaissent
des bornes mais nous exigeons cependant
que ces bornes soient fixées par la loi
et par elle seule
et nous demandons encore à la loi quand
elle fixe c'est bob de l'interdire que
les actions nuisibles à la société comme
l'exigent l'article 5 de la déclaration
des droits de l'homme et du citoyen or
qu'y at il de plus nuisibles à la
société que le terrorisme et le crime
organisé
encore faut-il que les bornes que nous
posons soient strictement limitées
à ce qui est indispensable à la
réalisation des objectifs d'intérêt
général que nous confions à l'état c'est
tout le sens du travail accompli par le
sénat et ce travail a été pleinement
reconnue par la commission mixte
paritaire qui s'est réuni le 16 juin
dernier
l'exigence de nous conformer aux
principes posés par la déclaration des
droits de l'homme et du citoyen a été
notre obsession tout au long de nos
délibérations
nous étions jusqu alors dans le non
droit nous voulons rentrer dans le droit
nous avons voulu créer le droit le
souhaite que nous y soyons parvenus ne
nous soumettrons bien sûr au contrôle
vigilant du conseil constitutionnel sur
tous les points sur lesquels le sénat a
entendu inscrire son empreinte de
défenseurs des libertés comme rapporteur
de ce texte je serais heureux monsieur
le président du sénat que vous puissiez
porter nos choix devant le conseil
constitutionnel
vous même afin que celui ci puisse se
prononcer sur l'ensemble de nos apports
et vérifier que les objectifs que nous
avons poursuivi ont bien été atteint si
ce texte est adopté par notre assemblée
et demain par l'assemblée nationale
il s'inscrira pleinement dans le respect
du principe de l'égalité en ce qui
concerne les techniques de renseignement
nous avons posé dans l'article 1er de la
loi et la commission mixte paritaire l'a
maintenu les principes de l'égalité que
devraient suivre
l'autorité pour mettre en oeuvre les
techniques de l'enseignement ça veut
dire
ça veut dire que les décisions de mise
en oeuvre des techniques de
renseignement devront procéder d'une
autorité ayant compétence pour le faire
cela veut dire que la procédure suivie
devrait être conforme à la loi
c'est un service de renseignement met en
oeuvre une technique de renseignement
sans passer par la procédure légale
il y aura illégalité cette illégalité
devra être sanctionné
cela veut dire aussi que les décisions
prises devront respecter les missions
confiées à chaque service qui les met en
oeuvre et ses missions sont définies
dans la loi
pas question qu'un service face à la
place d'un autre
ce que sept autres services seraient
habilités à faire
cela veut dire aussi que les techniques
de renseignement qui seront mises en
oeuvre devront l'être en justifiant la
réalité des menaces des risques des
enjeux invoqué pour obtenir
l'autorisation d'appliquer ces
techniques de renseignement
cela veut dire aussi qu'à chaque fois
qu'une technique de renseignements sera
utilisé elle devra répondre aux intérêts
fondamentaux de la nation qui sont
énumérés par cette loi et surtout cela
veut dire que les atteintes portées au
respect de la vie privée ou aux
garanties apportées à l'exercice de
certains mandats ou de certaines
professions devront être proportionnée
aux motifs invoqués l'arsenal juridique
mis à la disposition de la commission
nationale de contrôle des techniques de
renseignement à la suite de nos
délibérations garantie que le contrôle
des techniques de renseignement sera
pour la première fois dans l'histoire de
la république pleinement assurée
la commission mixte paritaire est
parvenu à un accord sur tous les points
sauf un
qui a fait irruption au cours de nos
débats mais s'échange préparatoire avec
le président rapporteur de la commission
des lois de l'assemblée nationale ont
été excellents la collaboration que nous
avons eues pour faire aboutir cette
commission mixte paritaire tu tiens à le
dire a été féconde
l'adoption de cette loi va faire
progresser l'état de droit le projet de
loi instaure nullement de surveillance
de masse il fait exactement le contraire
il ne prévoit que des surveillance
ciblée et compte tenu de ce que j'ai
rappelé à l'instant toute mesure de
renseignement qui ne serait pas ciblé
tomberait sous le coup du principe de
l'égalité dont nous avons défini le
contenu il faut à chaque fois viser avec
précision les éléments de fait et les
finalités qui justifieront la mise en
oeuvre des techniques de renseignement
dans le respect du principe de
proportionnalité le respect de la
proportionnalité fait partie de la
légalité
les apports du sénat tendant à renforcer
les pouvoirs de contrôle et les
garanties d'indépendance de la
commission nationale de contrôle ont été
intégralement repris par la commission
mixte paritaire
il en est de même de nombreux autres
apports qui visent tous à conforter la
constitutionnalité du projet de loi en
assurant le respect de nos droits et de
nos libertés en assurant aussi
l'effectivité du contrôle juridictionnel
que notre texte permettra de mettre en
oeuvre le compromis trouvé en commission
mixte paritaire me permet aujourd'hui de
vous présenter un texte en réalité très
proche de celui que vous avez adopté les
principes de la politique publique de
renseignement sont désormais claires le
cadre légal existe le compromis qui a
été trouvé sur le renseignement
pénitentiaire je tiens à le souligner
n'interdit pas la mise en oeuvre de
techniques de renseignement en prison au
contraire il permet de mettre en oeuvre
ces techniques de renseignement dans les
conditions du droit commun c'est bien
que un détenu ne sera pas davantage à la
brique n'importe lequel de nos citoyens
dans la surveillance seraient rendues
nécessaires en matière de renseignement
la procédure d'autorisation des
techniques a également était maintenue
par la commission mixte paritaire dans
les termes que lés sénat avait voté
nous avons souhaité que le premier
ministre et des ministres concernés
puissent choisir des représentants de
l'autorité publique librement autour
d'eux mais qu'on ne fonctionna ris pas
cette fonction qui doit rester une
fonction de responsabilité auprès de
l'autorité exécutive
nous avons demandé que la mise en oeuvre
des renouvellement d'autorisation soit
justifié de manière particulière cette
disposition est maintenue par la
commission mixte paritaire
nous avons voulu limiter les finalités
permettant la mise en oeuvre de la
procédure d'urgence absolue et clarifier
le recours à la procédure d'urgence
opérationnels ces dispositions ont été
reprises par la commission mixte
paritaire
nous avons voulu préciser le régime
spécifique applicable aux professions
protégées
là aussi le texte qui vous est soumis
aujourd'hui est fidèle à votre vote
précédent
la solution du sénat a également été
validé s'agissant du point de départ du
délai de conservation des informations
recueillies dans la mise en oeuvre des
techniques de renseignement ce point de
départ c'est le recueil de l'information
ça n'est pas le moment où cette
information est transcrite car sinon
cela laisserait à l'autorité
administrative toute latitude pour
décider du point de départ du délai
alors que ce point de départ doit être
objectif
je voudrais dire d'entrée de jeu que je
suis tout à fait favorable à
l'amendement que dépose le gouvernement
et qui répond d'ailleurs au souhait que
j'avais moi même exprimé en commission
mixte paritaire pour que nous ne
modifions pas le régime de surveillance
des citoyens étrangers de passage en
france sur le territoire national un
seul régime juridique doit s'appliquer
quelle que soit la nationalité des
personnes qui se trouvent sur notre sol
je crois que cet amendement se
heurtaient de toute façon à de solides
interrogations du point de vue de sa
constitutionnalité
nous avons également maintenue un
certain nombre d' apport du sénat sur la
composition de la commission nationale
de contrôle neuf membres et non pour la
13 sur la différenciation démission des
membres avec une formation restreinte
une formation plénière des pouvoirs
propres de certains des membres de la
commission qui sont tous magistrats ou
conseiller d'état de sorte que le
système que nous avons retenu est
intégralement préservé de même que les
pouvoirs de la commission de contrôle
nous avons voulu une commission de
contrôle avec de très larges pouvoirs
nous avons même créé un délit d' entrave
quand une administration s'opposer à
l'exercice de ses pouvoirs
nous avons voulu la commission soit
indépendante et qu'elle ait les moyens
de son indépendance nous avons voulu que
le président de la commission nomme lui
même et non pas le premier ministre ses
collaborateurs
tous ces points ont été intégralement
préservés par le travail de la
commission mixte paritaire et surtout le
point le plus crucial pour nous tous
c'était d'assurer la réalité du contrôle
juridictionnel des autorisations de mise
en oeuvre des techniques de
renseignement
or le texte que nous étions saisi
prévoyait bien la possibilité d'un
recours devant le conseil d'état mais
dans des conditions tellement
restrictives que l'on pouvait craindre
que ce recours n'est jamais lieu nous
avons maintenant un dispositif qui
permet à seuls trois membres de la
commission de contrôle de saisir le
conseil d'état
c'est à dire dans des conditions très
souple nous savons au moment où nous
voterons ce texte que le contrôle du
conseil d'état jouera effectivement et
nous pouvons naturellement être confiant
de la manière dont le conseil d'état
exercera ce contrôle il a maintes fois
dans son histoire prouver son sa qualité
de défenseur des libertés publiques
gageons qu'il le prouvera de nouveau
dans l'application de cette loi sur le
renseignement
quant aux techniques de recueil de
renseignements je ne reviens pas sur nos
débats nous avons apporté de nombreuses
garanties supplémentaires technique par
technique celles ci ont intégralement
été préservés de manière à ce qu'on
abuse pas de ces techniques dans des
cadres qui ne seront pas strictement ce
que la loi prévoit il ya également un
certain nombre de dispositions sur le
fichier judiciaire des auteurs
d'infractions terroristes à chaque fois
il faudra pour être inscrit dans ce
fichier
une décision du juge ou du procureur
si bien que nous arrivons à un texte qui
en vérité devrait satisfaire pleinement
le sénat tentent ils ressemblent aux
textes que nous avons adoptée il y à
quelques temps je voudrais souligner
également le renforcement des
prérogatives de la délégation
parlementaire au renseignement que
préside notre collègue le premier
ministre jean pierre raffarin et à la
suite des amendements qu'il a proposés
le contrôle de la négation délégation
parlementaire au renseignement à se
trouver élargi aux services de
renseignements appartenant à ce qu'on
appelle couramment le second cercle pas
les services de renseignements qui sont
inscrits dans la loi mais ceux qui
viendront s'ajouter par décret du
premier ministre
de même la délégation parlementaire au
renseignement recevra des statistiques
détaillées relatives à la mise en oeuvre
des techniques de renseignement par
finalité et par technique
de sorte que si nous constatons un
recours exagéré à certaines techniques
ou dans des conditions qui ne nous
satisfont pas nous pourrons saisir le
gouvernement de la nécessité en tout cas
de l'opportunité de modifier les
pratiques ou les textes enfin la
commission mixte paritaire a bien sûr
maintenu la clause de rendez vous que
nous avons tenu à ajouter au texte ce
texte comporte beaucoup de dispositions
évidemment sensible il faut en pouvoir
en faire le bilan
nous pourrons le faire à la lumière des
travaux de la délégation parlementaire
au renseignement
mais aussi à la lumière du rapport
annuel de la commission nationale de
contrôle des techniques de renseignement
si bien je crois que si ce texte est
adopté il sera tout à fait exemplaire de
notre volonté d'inscrire pleinement dans
la tradition de l'état de droit français
la mise en oeuvre de ces mesures de
police administrative que sont les
techniques de renseignement
contemporaine c'est la raison pour
laquelle je tiens cette après midi à
exprimer ma satisfaction des résultats
de la commission mixte paritaire est
naturellement à vous inviter à donner
une large majorité à l'adoption de ce
texte
merci monsieur le président
la parole est à monsieur bernard
cazeneuve le ministre l'intérieur
c'est le président monsieur le président
à porter cher philippe à monsieur le
premier ministre mesdames et messieurs
les sénateurs
la commission mixte paritaire qui s'est
tenue le mardi 16 juin s'est conclue par
un accord qui nous permet de nous réunir
aujourd'hui pour soumettre à votre
examen et je l'espère à votre
approbation
le texte issu des travaux réalisés par
les représentants de l'assemblée
nationale et du sénat
lorsque j'ai présenté ce texte devant le
sénat d'abord devant la commission des
lois et celle de la défense et des
affaires étrangères puis dans
l'hémicycle j'avais formulé le voeu que
dans la grande tradition républicaine
le sénat puis jouer tout son rôle pour
consolider juridiquement le texte
présenté par le gouvernement et amendé
par les députés en première lecture
non seulement ce voeu a été exaucé grâce
au travail remarquable conduit par les
sénateurs sous l'autorité du président
rapporteur philippe bas mais je tiens
aussi à souligner combien la version du
texte qui vous est soumis pour
approbation à l'issue de la commission
mixte paritaire est inspiré des travaux
que vous avez vous même réalisé durant
la première lecture lors de l'examen du
projet de loi vous avait forgé toute une
architecture de contrôle
reposant sur une idée simple et que je
trouve qu'on a pas incontestable plus
une technique du renseignement est
intrusive et plus à suppose des
garanties procédurales renforcer le
texte issu de la commission mixte
paritaire reprend très précisément cette
doctrine ce qui se matérialise par des
amendements incorporé au texte final
reprenant ceux adoptés par le sénat
je pourrais citer par exemple le délai
de conservation des interceptions de
sécurité courant à partir du recueil et
non de la première exploitation de la
saisine automatique du conseil d'état
pour autoriser une intrusion
domiciliaire après l'avis négatif de la
sncm ou encore les restrictions à
l'usagé du imsi catcheur ces amendements
provenant du sénat ont été pour
l'essentiel conserver
il en existe d'autres
je sais que le sénat fera ce travail
important d'inventaire qui démontre une
fois de plus l'ampleur de la
contribution de la haute assemblée dans
la rédaction de la loi
j'invite d'ailleurs chaque observateur
de la vie politique à s'y référer temps
les travaux sont incontestables
même si les paysages de faire de longs
discours à l'occasion de ses lectures
j'aimerais préciser la position du
gouvernement sur certains amendements
adoptés en commission mixte paritaire
commission qui réunit les députés les
sénateurs et à laquelle vous le savez
n'assiste pas le gouvernement
tout d'abord vous avez adopté deux
amendements et ont pour effet que les
techniques mises en oeuvre sur le
territoire national à l'égard de
ressortissants étrangers non résidents
n'est pas à faire l'objet d'un contrôle
de la scène s'était il s'agit d'une
proposition émanant du travail du
parlement
le gouvernement est défavorable il ya
même très défavorable à cette
proposition
pour des raisons de nature
constitutionnelle vous connaissez la
position constante du gouvernement
chaque mesure doit être appréhendée à
l'aune des garanties juridiques dont
elle est assortie la jurisprudence du
conseil constitutionnel est en effet
très restrictive quant aux possibilités
d'instituer des différences de
traitement au détriment des étrangers
même non résidents dans l'application de
la loi française sur le territoire
national en particulier il est difficile
d'admettre de telles différences lors ce
qui est en jeu le droit à la protection
de la vie privée
c'est la raison pour laquelle le
gouvernement vous propose de revenir sur
ses dispositions en adoptant des
amendements de suppression et s'engage à
convaincre les députés d'adopter des
amendements identiques pour ne pas
obérer la réussite de la lecture des
conclusions de cette cmp
par ailleurs deux amendements de
précisions sont soumis pour clarifier
les rédaction issue de la commission
mixte paritaire
naturellement le gouvernement a apporté
son aval aux amendements déposés par les
rapporteurs qui permettent de fluidifier
la rédaction issue de la commission
mixte paritaire
j'en arrive à une dernière disposition
sur laquelle le gouvernement ne dépose
pas d'amendement mais souhaite préciser
l'interprétation qu'il
ce fait du texte et l'application qu'il
en aura la cmp a souhaité rétablir une
disposition issue de l'assemblée
nationale relative à l'échangé
d'informations entre les services du
renseignement et entre les services des
autres administrations d'autre part je
tiens à préciser et je souhaite que cela
soit retenu au compte rendu de nos
travaux que ces dispositions seront
mises en oeuvre dans le strict respect
des exigences de proportionnalité pour
une finalité déterminée au profit de
service lit m limitativement énumérés et
dans le respect des missions des
services par exemple les services
réalise des signalements aux caisses
d'allocations familiales de
bénéficiaires de prestations sociales
parti se rendent sur un théâtre de
guerre et ne répondant plus aux critères
de résidence sur le territoire national
nécessaires à l'attribution de ces
allocations
afin qu'il soit mis un terme aux
versements et d'éviter ainsi de donner
une source de financement à des
activités terroristes
c'est dans ce type de cas très précis
très circonstancié avec des garanties
préservé que cette mesure sera mise en
oeuvre
voilà mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs les précisions que je
souhaitais formulée en remerciant une
fois de plus le président rapporteur
philippe bas le premier ministre jean
pierre raffarin et l'ensemble des
sénateurs pour la qualité du travail
qu'ils ont accompli tout au long de la
discussion de ce texte comme s'ils s'y
était engagé le président de la
république transmettra au conseil
constitutionnel le projet de loi au
terme de l'examen parlementaire comme le
lui autorise la constitution ce qui
permettra encore de renforcer toutes les
garanties autour de ce texte je vous
remercie encore une fois d'avoir
contribué par votre contribution à ces
débats à donner un cadre à l'activité
des services de renseignement dans un
contexte où les progrès de la
technologie ont fait leur oeuvre cadre
qui jusqu'à présent n'avait pas été
donnée à ces services et qui les
conduira désormais à intervenir sous
l'effet d'un double contrôle
celui d'abord d'une commission
administrative indépendante dont la
composition et les modalités de
fonctionnement garantiront un haut
niveau
contre je veux parler de la scène
c'était contrôle juridictionnel qui
pourra aller jusqu'à la saisine du juge
pénal lorsqu'il sera constatée par le
conseil d'état ou même par la scène ces
terres que dans le cadre de la
mobilisation d'une technique de
renseignement une infraction pénale aura
été commise contrôle parlementaire
renforcer puisque la délégation
parlementaire au renseignement disposent
désormais d'une possibilité d'effectuer
depuis son contrôle sur l'activité des
services de renseignement ce qui n'était
pas le cas avant cette saisie stature au
moment où cette délégation parlementaire
a été instituée c'est dire la volonté
qui est celle du gouvernement et de
l'ensemble de la représentation
nationale de faire en sorte que
l'activité des services de renseignement
permettent notamment lorsqu'il s'agit de
la lutte contre le terrorisme de
protéger résolument et fermement les
français contre des risques dont nous
avons vu à quel point lorsqu'il se
traduise par des actes
ils peuvent être meurtrier et conduire
la république à devoir affronter des
défis puisque ces actes sap la
république à ses fondements et par
ailleurs nous souhaitons aussi que cette
loi fasse rentrer notre pays dans la
liste des démocraties dont les services
sont les plus contrôlées de façon
exigeante et rigoureuse pour la
contribution qui a été la vôtre à
l'élaboration de ce texte je veux au nom
du gouvernement vous renouveler mes très
sincères remerciements
merci le soulève ministre la parole est
à monsieur jean pierre sueur pour 14
minutes
c
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues à ceux qui
s'interrogent sur le rôle du sénat
il en est toujours je conseillerais la
lecture de ce texte de projet de loi tel
qu'il est arrivé au sénat est tel qu'il
a été voté au sénat et je conseillerais
de surcroît la lecture du texte issu de
la commission mixte paritaire
chacun pourra voir que le sénat a pesé
lourdement dans l'écriture du texte et
que la commission mixte paritaire a
repris un très grand nombre d apport du
sénat
il faut le dire puisque cela est vrai et
que chacun pourra le constater c'est
dire que à mon tour je souscris aux
conclusions de la commission mixte
paritaire
à une exception notable qui a déjà été
noté sur laquelle je reviendrai un point
positif a été obtenu suite aux débats du
cdh a c'est que le ministère de la
justice soit exclu de la liste des
organismes de renseignement ayant la
faculté de mettre en oeuvre des
techniques intrusive cela était
contraire aux missions du ministère de
la justice et il était très nécessaire
qu'il y ait là dessus une parfaite
clarté
ça ne veut pas dire que le renseignement
pénitentiaire n'est pas utile il est
nécessaire nous l'avons dit je le redis
toutefois il est aussi nécessaire de ne
pas mélanger les fonctions il ne revient
pas à un surveillant pénitentiaire
d'être par ailleurs un agent de
renseignement sans cela tout est
confondu il n'y a plus de clarté mais il
faut que les services de renseignement
puissent oeuvrer dans le domaine
pénitentiaire
et il faut qu'il y ait des liens à cet
égard entre ses services et les services
pénitentiaires
et d'ailleurs je voulais dire à notre
rapporteur au fond monsieur philippe bas
que nous avions trouvé une rédaction ici
au sénat qui permettait de faire la
clarté sur ces relations pour nous
aurons l'occasion d'y revenir
en d'autres circonstances mais
l'essentiel était de préserver une
lecture très claire du projet de loi à
cet égard je voulais souligner un
certain nombre de points importants
en dehors de celui là d'abord grâce au
sénat grâce à l'amendement du groupe
socialiste on me permettra de le dire la
vie privée se trouve clairement définis
dans le texte
dans toutes ses composantes secret des
correspondances protection des données
personnelles inviolabilité du domicile
deuxièmement eux il est positif que
l'objectif majeur est là je remercie
l'assemblée nationale soit revenu je
vais faire quelques pen peut-être à
monsieur le premier ministre jean pierre
raffarin
mais je pense qu'il est préférable
s'agissant de la politique étrangère des
intérêts industriels de parler d'intérêt
majeur et surtout pour les intérêts
économiques auxquelles vous êtes à juste
titre très attaché cher jean pierre
raffarin je voulais dire qu'il me
paraissait quand même
impossible de parler des intérêts
économiques en général sans aucune
précision
donc cela le est arrivé au terme de la
cmp et c'est une bonne chose pour se
lier des délais de conservation des
données
il y a eu un compromis un compromis est
un compromis
toutefois le sénat a pesé dans ce
compromis puisque les dates seront
appréciées par rapport au recueil des
informations et non par rapport à leur
exploitation
d'autre part pour ce qui est des données
cryptées
il n'y avait pas dans le texte avant
l'arrivée du texte au sénat de délai
ceci faisait peser sur le texte un loup
risques d'inconstitutionnalité
c'est pourquoi il est heureux qu'au
terme de la commission mixte paritaire
un délai est été instauré pour ce qui
est de la commission de contrôle le
sénat a fait en sorte que ces pouvoirs
soient clairement étendue je prendrai
plusieurs exemples d'abord monsieur
philippe baladi trois membres de la
commission sur neuf pourront saisir en
toutes circonstances le conseil d'état
c'est important
deuxièmement nous avons obtenu que
monsieur le ministre de la défense 10 au
sénat est d'ailleurs monsieur le
ministre de l'intérieur vous avez
conforter cette réponse que y compris le
pnc 17 plateformes dont nous avons parlé
donnera lieu aux possibilités de
contrôle de la commission nationale de
contrôle des techniques de renseignement
c'est un point qui a été dit qui engage
le gouvernement et c'est une bonne chose
enfin toujours s'agissant du contrôle
je veux insister sur le fait que nous
avons pu et mon groupe il ya aussi
contribué pour une deuxième fois je me
permets de souligner inscrire on n'est
jamais mieux servi que par soi même
en effet monsieur mesa inscrire dans le
texte que le contrôle de la commission
sur l'ensemble des données
d'interception sera je cite direct
complet permanent ce qui veut dire que
face à certaines interrogations que nous
avons bien entendu sur le fait que
contrairement à une situation antérieure
les données pourraient être dispersées
en divers lieux et bien il y aura un
droit reconnu par la loi aux membres de
la
commission de disposer de ces données de
manière complète exhaustive direct sans
intermédiaire et permanence c'est à dire
à toute heure du jour et de la nuit 365
jours par an c'est important
s'agissant des techniques dont on a
parlé antique imsi catcheur et
s'agissant des algorithmes
il a été bien préciser les limites dans
lesquelles l'accès à ces techniques
étaient possibles et notamment le fait
que cela devait avoir pour seule
finalité la lutte contre le terrorisme
j'ai déjà eu l'occasion de dire qu'il
était nécessaire de surveiller un
certain nombre de sites
si on dit que ce n'est pas nécessaire
alors disons clairement qu'on ne veut
pas lutter contre le terrorisme
mais si on veut lutter contre le
terrorisme
on ne peut pas ne pas contrôler qui qui
se connecte sur des sites qui font
l'apologie du terrorisme qui présente
des heures qui présente des appels au
meurtre
et bien entendu il y aura des gens qui
se seront connectés par hasard et bien
il ne s'agit pas de les mettre en cause
aucunement
mais il est nécessaire de procéder à des
investigations sous le contrôle de la
commission et surtout les garanties en
respectant toutes les garanties
inscrites dans le texte
si l'on veut lutter contre le terrorisme
pour ce qui est du fichier national des
auteurs d'affaires d' infractions
terroristes
je me réjouis que l'on ait repris la
proposition émanant de l'assemblée
nationale selon laquelle l'inscription
sur ce fichier doit être le fruit ou les
faits plutôt d'une décision positive
d'une autorité judiciaire
pour ce qui est
de la protection des magistrats des
avocats des journalistes et des
parlementaires
la commission mixte paritaire a permis
une avancée supplémentaire puisqu'il est
clairement écrit dans la loi désormais
que ces personnes ne pourront faire
l'objet d'une surveillance à raison soit
de leur profession soit de leur mandat
le sénat avait beaucoup oeuvré en ce
sens c'est maintenant acté dans la loi
d'autre part je veux insister fortement
sur le fait que toutes les mesures qui
sont dans le texte sans aucune exception
sont des mesures qui procède du ciblage
de l'intentionnalité clairement
manifesté et jamais je dis bien jamais
du contrôle de masse c'est à dire du
fait de capter des milliards et des
milliards d'informations au détriment
des droits des personnes
nous sommes contre la captation massive
d'informations nous voulons que toutes
techniques soient mises en oeuvre dans
un but affiché déterminé
contrôlé avec les garanties nécessaires
de telle manière qu'il y ait aucun
détournement de la procédure
donc cela est clair et cela figure noir
sur blanc dans le texte
je terminerai en disant moi aussi qu'il
y a eu un amendement qui a été adoptée à
une voix de majorité par la commission
mixte paritaire relatives à la situation
des personnes étrangères présentes pour
un court séjour
cet amendement eux contre lequel pour ma
part j'ai voté mais je ne suis pas le
seul puisqu'un grand nombre de sénateurs
ont voté contre cet amendement
présente t risques constitutionnels
comme cela a été dit est plus que des
risques d'ailleurs il est clairement
inconstitutionnel vous l'avez dit
monsieur le ministre
il est contraire au principe d'égalité
et il pose problème tant sur le fond que
pour ce qui est de sa procédure
d'adoption puisque il n'est pas
souhaitable vous le savez bien que des
amendements fut stave adopté en
commission mixte paritaire
alors qu'ils n'ont donné lieu à aucun
débat ni à l'assemblée nationale ni au
sénat
pour ces raisons je vous indique que je
dis ici très clairement que le groupe
socialiste votera sans réserve
l'amendement numéro huit du gouvernement
monsieur raffarin je vous rassure
qui a pour effet de supprimer cet alinéa
qui a été introduit à une voix de
majorité lors de la commission mixte
paritaire
mes chers collègues pour la première
fois il existera dans ce pays
une loi encadrant les services de
renseignement l'action des services de
renseignement ce n'est pas neutre
cela n'existe pas et ce qui est quelque
peu paradoxal c'est que au moment où on
fait une loi pour encadrer par la loi
l'action des services de renseignement
on vient nous dire que nous porter en
tout que nous portons atteinte aux
libertés
c'est quelque peu paradoxal mais surtout
je tiens je me permet d'inciter certains
auteurs de telle ou telle tribune à lire
le texte parce que il est tout à fait
vrai que ce texte pose des problèmes il
est tout à fait clair que ce texte poser
des problèmes auxquels nous avons
répondu il est tout à fait clair que
c'est un sujet sensible mais je lis
parfois des déclarations des écrits qui
témoigne d'une absence de connaissance
de ce que le texte dit
de ce qu ils disposent or quand on lit
les choses dans le détail on voit mes
chers collègues et sans aucune
autosatisfaction d'aucune sorte
on reparlera du sujet dans cinq ans et
112 bien avant que nous nous sommes
efforcés d'atteindre le meilleur
équilibre possible et sans doute y at il
encore des améliorations la perfection
n'est pas de ce monde
des améliorations apportées mais nous
avons cherché à atteindre en toute bonne
foi le meilleur équilibre entre la
sécurité nécessaire car il vaut lutter
contre l'horreur du terrorisme et la
protection de nos libertés des données
personnelles de la vie privée car nous
pouvons le redire ici la plus grande
victoire des terroristes serait de nous
faire renoncer à nos libertés je vous
remercie
la parole est à madame esther benbassa
pour six minutes m
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre monsieur le président de la
commission des lois
monsieur le rapporteur michel collègues
67 sénateurs dont dix membres du groupe
écologiste se sont opposés à ce texte
comment peut-on encore adopté
aujourd'hui des lois
rappelant celle de george bush qui plus
est après les scandales que nous avons
connue et les révélations des doigts ce
modèle comme une qu'avons nous fait pour
mériter ce traitement anti démocratique
que nous laisserons en héritage aux
exécutive à venir qui pourraient se
révéler moins scrupuleux que celui
d'aujourd'hui
pourquoi cette surdité aux arguments
fondés de ceux qui s'opposent à ce pays
elle cette cécité face aux dangers
qu'ils présentent
avez-vous cédé au lobby des services de
renseignement qui n'ont pas jusqu'ici
démontré leur grande dextérité à déjouer
les attentats dont notre pays a été la
cible s avec les métadonnées qu'ils y
parviendront
quand on sait qu'ils n'ont pas pu suivre
des délinquants en processus de la dic
alisation religieuse malgré les
informations transmises par des
responsables des lieux de détention où
il s'était trouvé incarcéré seul il
fallait un test pour mettre fin aux
dérives aux pratiques non cadrée voire
illégales des services de renseignements
mais pas un texte comme celui dont nous
débattons à nouveau et qui met cette
fois légalement en péril nos libertés
personne ici ne peut être taxé de
laxisme ou d'un conséquence face au
terrorisme
mais il faut j'en suis certaine
lui opposer une résistance efficace est
consciente
sans jamais brader nos libertés première
cible justement des obscurantistes qui
nous visent je voudrais partager
avec vous mes chers collègues les propos
d'edouard snowden lanceurs d'alerté 6 la
neige qui résonne aujourd'hui d'une
manière bien singulière
je cite le fait de dire qu'on se fiche
de la vie privée parce qu'on n'a rien à
cacher revient à dire qu'on se fiche de
la liberté d'expression parce qu'on a
rien à dire le champ d'application de la
loi devait pour être acceptable être
davantage limité et définir de manière
précise et respectives les motifs
d'intérêt public justifiant la mise en
oeuvre des activités de renseignement
à la lecture du texte de la commission
mixte paritaire qui reprend dans son
ensemble la rédaction élaboré par notre
haute assemblée force est de constater
qu'on a mais loin au nom de la sécurité
et même s'il s'agit de lutte contre le
terrorisme
on ne peut pas placer entre les mains de
l'administration les pouvoirs
normalement dévolue aux juges pour
prévenir d'éventuelles conséquences
fâcheuses les pouvoirs de la commission
nationale des contrôles de techniques de
renseignement auraient dû être renforcé
nous avions d'ailleurs préconisé qu'elle
puisse lorsqu'on lui demande
l'autorisation de mettre en oeuvre une
mesure vérifier sans délai sans
restrictions que celles ci est
parfaitement légal proportionnée et
subsidiaire
non seulement ce n'est pas le cas dans
le test qui nous est soumis aujourd'hui
mais une disposition a été ajoutée à
l'initiative du rapporteur de
l'assemblée nationale comme l'ont dit
certains collègues autorisant le premier
mini ça avoir recours aux techniques de
l'enseignement sans avis préalable de la
scène ses terres
lorsque leur mise à neuf ne concerne ni
en français ni en résidence habituelle
en france le conseil constitutionnel
aurait probablement eu à examiner ces
dispositions contraires au principe
d'égalité devant la loi et nous
réjouissons de la volonté du
gouvernement de la supprimer
voilà avait donc pu suivre les
conclusions de la commission mixte
paritaire sur le projet de loi sur le
renseignement tout de suite fait preuve
par 3 michel grossiord et perrine
tarneaud reçoivent françois bayrou